hello everyone and welcome to a very
nice game from round six uh of the
currently played reykjavik open it's uh
icelandic grand master johann harterson
versus han smoke and niman and uh like i
said in the title of the video it's a
funny story but the funny stories about
why i'm actually showing this game but
we're gonna discuss that after i show
you the game so uh as not to spoil
anything so let's dive into it it's a
pretty short game so you guys will enjoy
it uh here arthurston has the white
pieces and he opens with c4 uh he will
not be four uh he goes for the english
opening we have e5 by niemann and going
for the king's english variation g3 we
have c6 uh d4 and now as the the pawn on
e5 is challenged we grab more space in
the center with e4 uh knight to c3 now
attacking the pawn and the black is very
happy to grab more space in the center
with the d5 and now usually bishop to g2
is just played here but harterson goes
for knight to h3 he's saying okay you've
advanced this pawn uh all the way to e4
now i'm gonna put my knights to f4 and
the only way for you to kick it away is
to play some like h5 h6 and g5 or to
somehow trade one of your pieces for my
knight but this will be an excellent
square for the knight so h6 uh we have c
cap percent d5 c captures and now queen
to b3 uh there is a game in the database
where knight to the e f4 was played
right away it's a game between enhanced
economy versus nils grandelius from 2013
that ended in a draw but here we have
queen to b3 going for a different
approach knight to f6 and only now
knight to f4 we have knights to c6 e3
now and bishop to b4 now pinning this
knight and there uh is a game uh where
uh
uh a move that that isn't the move in
this game was played but here we have
bishop to d2 and it is now already as of
move tended we have a completely new
game so let's see what happens here
bishop captures on c3 so we have a trade
bishop for knight bishop captures and
now as we said this knight can only be
dislodged by playing h6 and g5 or g5
right away but that seems a bit too
sharp g5 chasing away the knight knight
the e2 and now uh hunts just castles
here
and here you could consider something
like h4 it seems like a good idea you
want to open up the h file for your rook
the problem is here it would be
uh there's really no attack here because
the pawn on d4 and this pawn and d5 are
preventing you from doing any damage
with the queen and the bishop and h4
just doesn't do all that much we're
going to play a5 or even b5 as possible
we could or even developing the bishop
we can even give the b7 pawn away let's
say a3 and now bishop the g4 it's a very
very sharp position but black definitely
has the upper hand even if you grab the
pawn queen d6 we connect the rooks and
the black is the one who's attacking
here so instead heart arson plays h3
here takes away the g4 square from the
from the bishop on c8 and now rook to b8
now we're ready to play b5 a5 b4 and so
on so g4 now uh creating some outputs
for our knight i need to explain ig3
then maybe knight f5 or knight to h5 in
the future and b5 by niemann we have
queen back to d1 you could also maybe
try playing a3 to prevent b4 but uh son
even invites b4 now you could consider
a5 and then b4 uh niemann goes for b4
right away attacks the bishop bishop
back to d2 and now he says all right i
also have some very nice outposts here
for my for my knight so maybe knights d7
to g6 and then maybe to h for them to f3
uh not much white can do about this uh
so just knight to the e7 we have knight
to g3 both players just uh
re-maneuvering their knights to better
outposts uh knight to g6 and now rook to
c1 makes sense this is the only open
file on the board so you definitely want
your rook on this file knights the h for
now going after that f3 square and of
course the bishop p2 we have to guard
the f3 square and now uh there are uh so
many moves you could play here with
black because black's position is
somewhat better here you could start
with a5 just solidifying on the queen
side you could start bishop to d7 just
connecting your rooks and everything
or you could just take away white's
castling privileges with knight g2
checking if one knight back to h4 now or
what is white going to do about this
rook how are you getting it into the
game it's not easy for white however in
the game queen the b6 was played
probably anticipating that white will
maybe castle or something like that but
um jarterson does no such thing he plays
rook to c5 and it's an excellent square
for the rook black does not have a dark
square bishop and
well
it will take you some time but also
not only is it an excellent outpost for
for the rook uh in the future some ideas
like queen to a4 maybe rook to c6 will
come with a double attack on the queen
and the knight so there are some things
to consider here so bishop to a6 bishop
to d7 would have still been better but
bishop to a6 really allows white to get
back into the game and the black pretty
much drops the advantage because now
queen to a4 is a must because yes uh you
are going to attack that bishop twice
but you will also be threatening this
rook to c6 idea so queen to a4 now
black's idea of trading bishops
has to be played with bishop captures on
e2 or maybe even bishop to d3 is
possible here uh but then you have to go
into this rook c6 attacks the rook and
the knight queen goes back to defend the
knight we're going to play bishop
captures on b4 and already white is the
one who is taking control over the game
so after bishop captures an e2 we have
king captures on e2 and now queen to e6
getting the queen away
from this double attack uh but still
rook h to c1 doubling up on the c file
and now we have rook to b6 not allowing
this rook to c6 idea but that's exactly
what white plays you can't really stop
it because white controls the square
three times so rook to c6 now comes
queen to d7 and here just b3 asking
white would you do here a b3 is not
necessary you could also play knight's
day h5 which is a which is a quicker way
to achieve victory but it doesn't matter
even after b sorry even after b3 uh
black does not have all that many
options here so rook captures on c6 was
played rook captures on c6 now putting
pressure on that knight here b3 was
played to keep an eye on the queen so we
could capture the knight and not hang
our queen so queen d8 attacking the
knight here but of course there are so
many uh ways to win the game now i'm
sure you guys see the cleanest one so
feel free to pause the video here and
win the game for white
while i give you a couple of seconds
so uh for those of you who were able to
do it congratulations on spotting this
brilliancy and for those of you who just
want to enjoy the show it's bishop
catrus and b4 now or you could go queen
captures an a7 or queen a6 white
position is so much better that pretty
much any move wins uh but bishop
captures on b4 is just resigns on the
spot and that's exactly what happened
here after bishop captures on b4 it was
in this position that han smoke and even
resigned the game because your rook is
hanging and there's no way to defend it
once you move the rook now white
captures on f6 and that's it queen
captures we we pick up a free rook white
is up a piece of course the position is
completely winning so after bishop b4 uh
neiman resigned and a brilliant
brilliant victory only 27 moves for
johan carter's on icelandic grand master
uh so while uh this game is very very
impressive and the very short one i
mentioned that it's a funny funny story
why i'm even showing it
a a large chess website posted on
twitter uh that shall not be named uh
posted that a brilliant brilliant game
was played in round six of the icelandic
uh icelandic open tournament and i
immediately it got my attention i
started analyzing it and i was like okay
it's a pretty pretty great game but uh
nothing that they've mentioned that
happens in the game actually happened in
this game so
they uh
misposted they said that it happened in
round six where as the game that they
were talking about happened in round
four so i already analyzed the game from
round six and it was a very very nice
one you can see there was a very clean
win so i decided to show both of them uh
so the ra the game from round four will
be shown in a video after this video so
you guys will be treated to two very
nice videos uh interestingly both played
by uh a very strong icelandic
grandmaster johan carter son
uh so yeah that's that's the game hope
you guys enjoyed it it's one of the
weirder reasons why i've shown a game uh
since i've started in my channel but uh
you know it's uh always nice when things
work out as it's it's it's it's a
wonderful game
i would like to thank
e usfdefre elias fine leonel alexandrino
harishriniwasan and that to dude lb for
a contribution to my channel thank you a
lot i really appreciate it as usual you
can check two of my previous videos here
thank you for watching and i will see
you soon uh with the other game that
i've mentioned where something truly
spectacular happens so stay tuned for
that it should be uh published maybe an
hour after this game is published uh so
yeah once again uh hope you guys enjoyed
it and have an excellent rest of your
day